okay so it turns out that Taylor Swift
on February 10th is doing a show in
Tokyo on February 10th the Super Bowl is
February 11th so if she left Tokyo at
midnight she would arrive somewhere in
Las Vegas around 11:00 a.m. on February
10th um the flight time is 11 hours and
35 minutes approximately from Tokyo to
Vegas um so she might arrive at like
10:35 p. but on February 10th leaving
her a full night sleep and so she really
could make it to the Super Bowl if just
if it happens to like come true so also
I checked to see if there's a flight and
there is leaving Tokyo at 12:50 p.m. um
at Han airport which then gets her in at
550 to LAX and then that's just a quick
hop from LAX um so it's possible